but first I want you to understand the
most crucial part of bar Senate
testimony and what it tells us about
where we're going over the next several
months and beyond all the fake outrage
over Bob Muller disagreeing with bars
release of the summary without his
summary and the slanderous attacks on
the Attorney General today this is the
most important thing to know we first
heard that the special counsels decision
not to decide the obstruction issue at a
meet at the March 5th meeting when he
came over to the department and we were
frankly surprised that that they were
not going to reach a decision on
obstruction and we asked them a lot
about the reasoning behind this and the
basis for this special counsel Muller
stated three times to us in that meeting
in response to our questioning that he
emphatically was not saying that but for
the OLC opinion he would have found
obstruction okay this is stunning what
all of this means is that despite all
the chatter and gossip hair-pulling
today despite the continuing leaks
Muller was unable to find obstruction
and further the Justice Department their
long-standing opinion from the OLC that
a sitting president cannot be indicted
had no bearing on Muller's findings
notice that the legal geniuses over at
MSNBC did not interrupt their live
coverage of the hearing to highlight
what I just shared with you because they
were too busy doing fantastical
real-time fact checks which I'm going to
show you in just a moment but this was
my favorite description of the day
special counsel investigation started by
his hand-picked Deputy Attorney General
we will continue to hear from the
president's hand-picked attorney general
Trump's hand-picked attorney general at
William Bar this behavior by his a
hand-picked attorney general this Roy
Cohn type guy who's working for him not
the country no wait second was the
Attorney General and the Trump
administration supposed to be picked by
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer what
would they prefer a randomly selected
age you just pull someone off the street
or maybe we can just go to a lottery
system instead every
general is selected by the sitting
president he serves at the pleasure of
the president every single one of them
so these people in these other media
outlets they don't know no just basic
government functioning I guess or they
just spinning foolishness and the media
we're not alone and their slanderous
attacks on bar of course having
determined that there was no Trump
Russia collusion Democrats have now
moved on to a trump bar collusion
narrative I think history will judge you
harshly that conclusion is inescapable
you've not only put your own credibility
into question but seem to be giving
sanction to behavior through the
language you used in that press
conference you held you lied and now we
know being Attorney General of the
United States is a sacred trust you have
betrayed that trust
America deserves better you should
resign you slandered this man from top
to bottom
senator Graham of course is a hundred
percent correct if the Democrats want to
impeach this president on the basis of
this Muller report I say you know you
try it you go for it kids you have the
whole report you got all 448 pages
none of the Democrats by the way have
actually gone to view the fully
unredacted report they can go they can
go to the special room of the Justice
Department if they're so set about you
know set on this idea of impeaching
Trump go look at the full report
unredacted you know only two people have
gone to see it both Republicans these
people are complete and utter frauds if
you think you have the evidence to
impeach roll the dice let's see what you
got guys let's see what you have see
where it ends up but in the midst of his
congressional harassment today Barr
explained how the special counsel
process actually works his work
concluded when he sent his report to the
Attorney General at that point it was my
baby and I was making a decision as to
whether or not to make it public and I
effectively overrode the regulations use
discretion to to lean as far forward as
I could
good to make that public and was my
decision how and when to make it public
not Bob Muller's and the job of the
Justice Department is now over that
determines whether or not there's a
crime the report is now in the hands of
the American people everyone can decide
for themselves there's an election in 18
months that's very democratic process
but we're out of it we have to stop
using the criminal justice process as a
political weapon bingo that was the key
moment from today
and by the way particularly when there
was no criminal wrongdoing discovered by
Muller zero he couldn't do the interview
with the president he didn't want to go
to court to try to get to sit down with
the president because he knew would lose
so let's break this down for some of the
armchair legal analysts out there there
is no disagreement about the central
facts of Muller's investigation fact one
there was no criminal conspiracy with
Russia some people call that collusion
none fact 2 while the Muller report did
find possible instances of obstructive
behavior it did not come to a conclusion
to recommend prosecution it's a binary
choice either-or the rest just window
dressing the inconsequential rantings of
fanatics who didn't get what they wanted
and they're bitter and they're clinging
to the old narrative that went nowhere
the criminal prosecution of the
presidents of President of the United
States wasn't going to happen it didn't
happen